hello I am David Kaplan and I am NOT an
expert but I hope in this series to
learn as much as possible and explain it
to you the best way I can how did life
begin or at least how did life begin on
earth this is a question that many of us
are curious about and biologists are
working extremely hard to try to figure
it out one possible way this could have
happened is that there was a single or
single type of biological molecule that
eventually evolved into all of life now
a reason to think something like that
might have happened is that all life we
know on earth contains the same
biological molecules namely DNA RNA and
amino acids RNA is particularly
interesting because not only does it
encode genetic information
it also can act as a catalyst for
chemical reactions so one hope is that
RNA formed in the early times on the
earth before there was life and then
began to replicate itself so that sounds
may be very simple but it's
extraordinarily complicated first simply
by the fact that we don't know what the
early earth looked like however there
has been some progress in creating
subunits of RNA in a laboratory with
very simple chemical compounds an
ultraviolet light a subunit of RNA is a
phosphate molecule of sugar molecule and
a base there are four kinds of bases we
can label them with letters a GU and C
and those letters in a sense when you
have a strand of them tell a story they
contain an enormous amount of
information and there is your genetic
code
so if in a lab you can see how just from
chemical processes you can produce a
subunit of RNA and then watch RNA grow
and eventually if it's possible have it
replicated itself then you've at least
demonstrated the possibility of how life
could have formed now of course life
could have started not with RNA but
something even before that with
molecules that don't exist now it's a
proto RNA or perhaps life actually came
from another planet it landed here on a
meteor and it began to grow once it
found the favorable conditions of the
earth we don't know but our best way of
figuring it out is going through the
processes of reproducing what may have
happened at the beginning of life